نحن نسير على الطريق الصحيح لتطوير
وتوزيع لقاح قبل
نهاية العام وربما
بشكل كبير قبل سوء الفهم.
كم من الوقت سيستغرق الأمر جيدًا يقول الدكتور أنتوني
فوسي إن
ذلك يعتمد على بعض العوامل ،
فاعلية اللقاح
هي ستين بالمائة ، وسبعين بالمائة ، وسبعين بالمائة ،
وتسعين بالمائة.
يوضح هذا الشهر أن 51 في المائة من المستجيبين يقولون
إنهم سيحصلون على اللقاح
ولكن هذا الرقم انخفض كثيرًا عن مايو
عندما
قال 66 إنهم سيحتاجون الآن بمجرد الموافقة على اللقاح
أو الموافقة
عليه سيستغرق الأمر شهورًا
لتوزيعه ، نتوقع أن يكون هناك ما يكفي لكل
أمريكي  يريد لقاحًا
بحلول مارس حتى أبريل 2021 حتى ذلك الحين ،
يذكرنا مدير مركز السيطرة على الأمراض السابق الدكتور توم فريدن
جميعًا باحتياطات الصحة العامة التي شاركناها
ما زلنا في الممارسة ضروريًا لبعض
الوقت ، ما زلنا بحاجة إلى تعديل
حياتنا
لتقليل المخاطر من خلال ارتداء الأقنعة وعدم المصافحة
لتقليل التجمعات الداخلية المحفوفة بالمخاطر ، وفي
النهاية
هذه هي الطريقة التي يمكنك بها احتواء هذا
المفهوم
الخاطئ للفيروس.  أنت أكثر
عرضة للإصابة بالطمع 19.
لقد رأينا هذه الحجة يتم دفعها على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي حتى زعمنا أن هناك
دراسة تدعمها
ولكن الدراسة التي تمت الإشارة
إليها نُشرت العام الماضي
قبل ظهور فيروس كورونا الجديد
، واقترحت أن لقاح الإنفلونزا
ربما  أن تكون مرتبطة بزيادة خطر
الإصابة بفيروس كورونا الموسمي مثل تلك
التي تسببت في نزلات البرد
في الواقع ، أوضح المؤلف مؤخرًا أن
نتائج الاقتباس من هذه الدراسة لا ينبغي
تطبيقها أو تفسيرها مع covid19
بأي شكل من الأشكال ، الحقيقة هي الأكثر
أهمية هذا
العام  الحصول على فهم خاطئ للقاح الأنفلونزا 3
أقنعة لا توقف انتشار
فيروس كورونا ، آمل
أن يتم التصويت على كل واحد منكم
لمن يصوت  سيد اليوم
عندما تم طلب تفويض القناع في بالم
بيتش فلوريدا في 24 يونيو
، لم يكن الأمر خاليًا من الجدل ولكن
أصبح العلم واضحًا أن
ارتداء القناع هو أحد أكثر
الطرق فعالية لوقف انتشار
الطمع 19.
دعني أحاول و  تظهر لك دراسة في
لانسيت أن فرصة
انتقال الفيروس بدون قناع وجه أو
جهاز تنفس
هي 17.4 مع قناع
3.1 وهل تتذكر حالة
هذين المصففي الشعر في ولاية ميسوري
استمروا في العمل أثناء مرضهم
بالطمع 19
ولكن  لقد ارتدوا أقنعة فقط للتوضيح ،
يجب على الأشخاص البقاء في المنزل إذا
شعروا بالمرض ،
ولكن عندما نظر مركز السيطرة على الأمراض في هذا الأمر ،
اكتشفوا أنه لا توجد إصابات جديدة
تم تحديدها
بين المصممون 139 عميلًا ،
لماذا يقول مركز السيطرة على المجتمع
إن سياسة تغطية الوجه للمجتمع والشركة من
المحتمل  يخفف من انتشار المرض يرتدي قناعًا
يساعدك على حماية من حولك دكتور
سانجاي جوبتا سي إن إن أتلانتا